hey 42 here for this video I've teamed
up with AI torquey to give you guys 10
US dollars worth of language lessons I
talkie is a community where you can
become fluent in any language by taking
lessons with online teachers from around
the world you can find a teacher that
suits your budget schedule and learning
style the one-on-one lessons are taking
on skype and afterwards you can practice
what you've learned of the community of
learners just click on the link below to
sign up and get your $10 voucher via
email there are estimated to be around
6500 spoken languages in the world today
but more than half the world's
population uses only 20 of them and the
language dies out every 14 days the most
spoken language is Mandarin with 955
million native speakers followed by
Spanish with 470 million and then
English with 360 million but how did
language originate and why don't we all
speak the same language let's find out
Homo sapiens have been on earth for
around 7 million years and modern humans
as we know them today have been around
for 200,000 years the human race is
ancient but we've only been able to
communicate with each other via language
for a rather short 100,000 years
scientists believe that humans have
always possessed the building blocks for
language but it wasn't until a hundred
thousand years ago when a chance
mutation occurred in a single human that
put the final building block in place
inside the brain which enabled humans to
finally be able to talk using legible
words it's thought that the very first
words were emulations of noises that
would have been heard in nature such as
the noises of animals and the wind
blowing through the trees scientists
theorized that the very first words
spoken by humans could very well have
sounded like these bow-wow poop
ding-dong yogi ho and Tata
but the truth is we know very little
about primitive languages because
writing wasn't developed until much
later and without writing we have almost
no evidence of ancient languages the
first written language we have found
evidence for is ancient Egyptian we have
found Egyptian hieroglyphs dating back
as far as 2,690 BC but why do we have
different languages wouldn't it be much
simpler if we all just spoke the same
language to understand this we must
first understand how languages develop
thousands of years ago isolated
civilizations across the globe all had
the same problem they needed a way to
describe the things they owned the tools
they used and the things they did to
their fellow citizens so they came up
with words for all their tools
possessions and action these names would
start with one person calling an object
by a made up word and after affirming to
adults that word for sometime other
people would begin calling it by the
same name and eventually the word would
stick this enabled them to work together
more efficiently and get more done today
we can get from one side of the planet
to the other in just a few hours but
back then travel took so long that
people just didn't bother this meant
that most groups of people were in
isolation from the rest of the world
this led to thousands of different
groups of people coming up with
thousands of different words for various
objects that's why some people may call
us in Apple whilst others will call it
apart over time these isolated groups of
people met with other isolated groups of
people when this happened they needed a
common way to describe objects so they
both adapted their self towards
languages to create a new language that
was a mix of the bow this happened time
and time again and after enough groups
of people mixed our languages together a
new super language was created which was
a combination of all the subgroups this
would eventually grow to become one of
the men
the languages we know today such as
English or friends but proximity has a
huge effect on how languages develop
countries next to each other often share
similar words for example tree in French
is our break tree in Italian is Alvaro
and tree in Spanish is arbol whereas
countries far away from each other
have virtually zero similarities in
their languages this is why the English
alphabet looks so different to say the
Japanese alphabet because both languages
were developed in complete isolation
from one another however in the modern
day where everyone is so well connected
and we can communicate with people on
the other side of the world in just
seconds wouldn't it be beneficial if we
all just spoke the same language many
predict that a single global language
would significantly increase
collaboration and productivity and some
groups have actually pushed for a
universal language but all attempts to
do so have so far failed the problem is
that if the world were to adopt a
universal language
he would have to give up their native
tongue and who gets to keep it it's not
an easy decision language is just too
deeply embedded within our culture's to
just give it all to do so we'll be
surrendering your country's culture and
history so for the foreseeable future
languages as we know them today are here
to stay but language doors change and
quite rapidly in fact in the short time
we've had the internet the English
language has already changed quite
considerably in march 2011 the oxford
english dictionary officially recognized
long as a word but what will the english
language look like in a thousand years
from now well Justin beer I challenged
this question taking all the effects of
different cultures and technology into
consideration he proposed a new language
future II
Justin took the following sentence we
children beg you teacher that you should
teach us to speak correctly because we
are ignorant and we speak corruptly and
translated it into future ease to
illustrate what it might look like in a
thousand years time he came up with this
when pronounced correctly
it reads Zakir ode we Xiang Yu T Zog do
ya guard reading cotton Wu Sargon lead
Lac who's been you Gordon and woosh are
cool quite a mouthful sounds like
something from a science fiction film
doesn't it but you can just imagine
people speaking something similar to
this in the year 3000 and finally I'll
leave you with these facts there is a
language in Botswana that consists of
mainly five types of clicks most
languages have over 50,000 words or more
but most speakers only know and use a
fraction of them in fact in everyday
conversation people only use the same
few hundred words
India is home to a menagerie of
different languages 780 different
languages are spoken in India however
220 of them were lost in the last 50
years thanks for the view subscribe for
more 40 tick
you